Democratic presidential candidate
senator Cory Booker raised more than
five million dollars that puts him right
in the middle of the pack the New Jersey
senator spoke with Face the Nation
moderator Margaret Brennan in his
hometown of Newark where he held a
weekend rally to launch his national
campaign worker talked about issues in
the race including immigration do you
think this is an empty threat by the
president though to talk about busing
people from the border into these
sanctuary cities he likes to create
frictions sometimes to jump start he
says a Congress that's not acting you
say friction I say he's trying to pet
Americans against each other and make us
less safe because what you're seeing now
so you take that threat seriously
III take this he is injecting fear into
our country he is fear-mongering and
what does that done for communities like
mine and are all across this country as
you have immigrant communities that are
now afraid to drop their kids off at
school now afraid to give information to
the police that we need to protect
cities like Newark and so if he was
looking to solve a problem he wouldn't
be doing things to divide this country
against itself where of any anybody
that's trying to tell you to be afraid
in the strongest country in the world as
opposed to showing our strength and our
courage by pulling people together to
find common sense solutions to solve
this problem you actually think that's
possible that candidate Cory Booker and
Senator Cory Booker could work with the
Trump administration going into an
election year on immigration reform I'm
the guy that just worked with the Trump
administration to pass the first in my
lifetime comprehensive criminal justice
reform that thou moving us away from
mass incarceration I had constant cost
conference calls with people in the
White House to work out a deal
buying president United States I will
not violate our values I will not
violate human rights I will keep our
country safe and find a bipartisan
comprehensive immigration reform a law
that honors dreamers that gives people
pathways to citizenship and does more to
protect our border congresswoman Ilhan
Omar she's being criticized for way she
phrased a reference to 9/11 and
president Trump has since posted a video
of the towers falling and her image
interspersed with that what do you make
of this back and forth you know I live
in
a community where we know folks who were
killed New Jerseyans were killed friends
of mine were killed in those towers and
in the aftermath of that you saw how our
country United put aside partisan
differences to deal with the challenges
to America and now years later to see a
President of the United States to use
images of 9/11 in a vicious crass
disgusting way that is so objectionable
that is so offensive and and this is
what I mean about moral vandalism in our
country that's going on from the highest
offices stoking hatred stoking fears
pitting people against each other you
have put forward a bill to study the
possibility of giving reparations to
repair the original sin if you as you
refer to it of slavery in this country
how would that work
how would reparations work well first of
all I don't know that's why I want to I
want to study I want to bring the breath
Minds together so I don't have all the
answers and so I put a bill in that
simply says hey let's talk about a lot
of these issues and wounds go back and
going back to slavery and figure out a
way how we can maybe do things today
that can help us to balance the economic
scales and have a country where we all
do well because I feel like we're
getting to a point in America where
we're talking about tolerance they were
a nation of Tolerance it's just that's
something proud to be about tolerance
says I mean heck go home tonight and
tell somebody you live with it you
tolerate them that's not a big
compliment there are a lot of
communities who are not getting their
fair shake and I think it's about time
we talk about that directly and do
things to try to make sure that
everybody ultimate reset more we
recognize the sort of animal rights that
all in this country are created equal
that phrase moral vandalism I think yes
directly really strikes me that makes a
lot of sense and I you can see exactly
what he's saying there you know as I
said earlier Margaret had done this this
interview for Face the Nation we're
going to put it up online so you can see
the full interview she emailed me over
the weekend and said it's very strong
very powerful they walk through the
streets of Newark hit a very successful
launch this weekend and they covered a
lot of subjects
he's ready for the long haul honk as he
says